et on parle depuis un moment de viande
et ça fait quelques années qu'on nous
parle de viande et il y a eu il a été
évoqué le sourcing de ces produits et
finalement tôt tard ça va finir par nous
échapper ce sourcil qui est dans ce mot
viande moi je pense qu'il y a déjà un
trompe l'oeil presque une tromperie et
qu'on va vers une industrialisation
massive de l'alimentation donc un
appauvrissement encore plus fort
culturel quand j'entends parler de foie
gras ça une histoire quelques années on
a massifié la production de foie gras et
finalement le foie gras est devenu un
produit assez banal et on continue
là-dedans pour encore plus de revenus
plus d'industrialisation plus
d'appauvrissement culturel et c'est ce
qui m'inquiète un petit peu dans ces
dans ces travaux parce que sa
pourrissement culturel conduit à ne plus
pouvoir à un moment donné permettre de
revenir à une idée assez gastronomique
plaisir bien-être santé que doit être
l'assiette et un moment donné quand on
veut répondre et j'entends les enjeux
pour pas que la France soit à la traîne
mais finalement la France n'a plus le
pouvoir de dire ça stop non on en veut
pas chez nous donc en gros ça ça me gêne
un petit peu en tant qu'artisan
maintenant en tant que chercheur
j'écoute le propos mais je n'arrive pas
à me déconnecter de cette idée de déjà
de vouloir massifier encore plus
l'industrialisation de notre nourriture
et donc de cette mondialisation et de
cette approhérissement culturel et
encore une fois on ramène tout sur la
consommation et sur le prix pas assez
sur la culture savoir manger c'est
savoir être c'est redonner du sens à son
alimentation se restaurer c'est quelque
chose qui veut dire quelque chose en
terme de lien social on l'oublie c'est
c'est très important sinon on peut
effectivement se nourrir comme à la
Pitié-Salpêtrière avec une perfusion
et j'ai pas de problème donc de m'amener
dans l'idée dans l'idée de fantasmer que
ce serait un pseudo foie gras une pseudo
viande donc je n'ai même plus le pouvoir
du sourcing du produit j'ai un peu de
mal avec ça par contre j'entends le
propos de dire il faut que la France ne
soit pas à la traîne de la recherche et
ce qu'on sache pourquoi on en veut et
pourquoi on en veut pas et ça ça me
paraît intéressant de ramener aussi
cette discussion sur le social et que
l'agriculture est là du sens et un sens
social et culturel et là on part encore
dans ce que j'entendais dans ce que je
lisais sur les 70 sur cette théorie du
low cost sur du tout pas cher renoncé à
la qualité en échange pas on fera manger
pas cher et on vous laissera croire en
fonction de ça que vous avez du pouvoir
d'achat c'est une manipulation des
masses moi qui me gêne pardon de parler
comme ça